[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JIT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité au sommaire de ce
journal 10 jours après le lancement des
solde divers nous irons à la rencontre
de ces commerçants qui refusent de
sacrifier leur stock consommer moins
mais mieux c'est sur ce principe que
certains commerçants se basent nouveaux
modèles économique refus de la
surconsommation ou simple stratégie
marketing des commerçants expliquent
leur choix à notre partenaire via
Occitanie tout n'est qui coule c'est
l'autre grand classique de ce début
d'année les températures hivernales
mettent pour certains les organismes à
rue d'épreuves un terrain propice au
retour de pathologie bien connu c'est ce
qu'a constaté OOT TV la chaîne de la
voie du Nord auprès de l'antenne SOS
médecin à Amien le froid est bien là
mais la neige en tout cas dans les
vauges est encore rare alors faute de
neige ce Mchel Laurin s'entraîne sur un
quad vous allez le voir notre partenaire
vos TV l'a rencontré avant qu'Antoine
gamin ne s'envole vers la Norvège pour
disputer l'une de ses mythiques cour de
traîneau à chien enfin après avoir servi
de mairie de tribunal de collège ou de
lycées et même de préfecture de la Sarte
lors de la guerre franco-prusse par
exemple en 1870 le château de silé le
Guillaume refait une beauté historique
des travaux prévus en deux phases
jusqu'en 2025 afin qu'il retrouve son
aspect
d'origine mais commençons ce journal
avec le nouveau coup de colère des
agriculteurs de la région Occitanie à
l'appel de la FRSEA la Fédération
Régionale des syndicats d'exploitants
agricoles et des jeunes agriculteurs
Toulouse a été le théâtre d'une nouvelle
manifestation d'envergure ce mardi près
de 1000 manifestants et plus de 400
tracteurs étaient dans les rues de la
ville rose afin de porter les multiples
revendications des agriculteurs de la
région revenu en Bern problématique
d'accès à l'eau directive européenne
frein à l'installation et au
renouvellement des générations plusieurs
lieux publicqus dans la préfecture ont
fait l'objet de déversement de purin des
actions condamnées par les pouvoirs
publics et notamment la ville de
Toulouse bien que ce soit de saison leur
dev venture n'affiche pas forcément
moins 30 ou moins 50 %. certaines
marques de vêtements aujourd'hui
refusent le modèle des soldes alors
difficile se de connaître le nombre
exact de ces commerçants qui refusent ce
principe devenu pourtant une tradition
mais une chose est certaine pratiquer
des Rabé pour ces entreprises souvent
made in France c'est hors de question
que ce soit pour des raisons écologiques
économiqu ou social regardez ce
reportage signé Antoine m et jofrey
Priol et Louise Anne pour via
ocitan un peu ce qu'on dites ce que vous
voulez choisir le bon jean avec la bonne
teinture le défi de Fran qui profite de
sa journée pour faire quelques achats
dans cette boutique éphémère de
Montpellier elle héberge la marque
l'érienne tufer spécialisée dans le jean
depuis plus d'un siècle il est déjà
coupé on va voir ok Franck repart avec
un pantalon et lors du passage en
caisse aucun Rabet sur le produit même
en pleine période des soldes pour Franck
pas de problème achet français c'est
avant tout un acte citoyen merci
beaucoup pour vous monsieur merci
promouvoir l'emploi en France et le
savoir-faire français et ben il faut
savoir à ce moment-là acheter son suite
en France son son jean en France et ne
pas avoir peur de le de le dire ça a du
sens aussi ça a du sens à niveau social
on est content d'avoir une joli boutique
dans le corps de montpolier on peut pas
demander 50 % de remise aussi car
effectuer ces 50 % de remise reviendrait
carrément à brader le travail des 30
salariés de l'entreprise ce sont eux qui
confectionnent les jeans dans les
ateliers situés à Florac en loszer on
préfère vendre à leur vraie valeur nos
pantalons toute l'année plutôt
qu'effectivement vous les vendre plus
cher toute l'année pour bah pour faire
croire au consommateurs qu'au moment des
soldes ils font des bonnes affaires et
en plus au prix où on les vend
actuellement on serait incapable de
proposer des discounts tels qu'ils sont
proposés dans certaines grandes
enseignes ce refus des soldes par ces
marques mine France est d'ailleurs dans
l'air du temps d'après les représentants
des professionnels de l'habillement
notamment avec les enjeux liés au climat
pense qu'il y a un rééquilibrage d'abord
qui s'est fait sur la déconsommation qui
a eu lieu un petit peu C dernières
années sur de nouvelles attitudes des
consommateurs donc oui les fabricants
adaptent leur stock le stock coûte cher
à tout le monde dans tous les cas et
l'éthique c'est quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui est bien ancré dans les
esprits à tous les échelons de de du
prête àorter de notre industrie et de
notre commerce donc oui on essaie de
réduire nos stocks c'est financièrement
et éthiquement plus intéressant
aujourd'hui l'industrie de la mode est
considéré comme l'une des plus
polluantes 3,3 milliards de tonnes de
CO2 rejeté chaque année au consommateur
donc de trouver le juste équilibre entre
quantité qualité et
budget la chute récente des températures
a mis les organismes à rue d'épreuves un
terrain propice au retour de pathologie
bien connu M de tête de gorges troubles
respiratoires sont autant de symptômes
de maladies hivernales classiques tels
que le rhume ou la grippe résultat
depuis plusieurs jours les patients se
bousculent dans les cabinets médicaux
c'est le cas à l'antenne SOS MDE saint
Damien où chaque jour près de 500
patients poussent les portes de la
structure en quête d'un remède à leur
mot c'est un reportage de Jérôme Bron
pour notre partenaire wotv de la voie du
Nord alors 6 c'est la période de rush
dans cette antenne SOS médecin des
patients par dizaine se suivent et bien
souvent les symptômes se ressemblent
c'est le mal de gorge et tête donc c'est
plutôt le grippe donc un petit peu de
grippe donc à cause de froid puis la
température quoi dites a a maux de gorge
tout nez qui coule ces grands classiques
de l'hiver se multiplient aidés par les
récentes chutes de température résultat
près de 500 personnes sont chaque jour
prises en charge par cette structure on
est dans les pathologies hivernales du
type rinopharingite S gripau qui peuvent
être la grippe ou bah le covid et puis
après bon on les pathologies
habituelles angine mal de gorge
autitte et cetera alors dans les
officines les traitements symptômatiques
bien connus reviennent en tête des
ventes on a des spray antiseptiques
respiratoires on a le traditionnel
ferveex quand il y a une douleur
associée quand il y a de la fièvre et
bien sûr qu'on a du doliprane aussi mais
si les incontournables paracétamol sont
présents en stock d'autres médicaments
manquent cruellement à l'appel c'est
encore le cas de laamoxyiline
antibiotique le plus préscrit en France
j'ai plus
d'unoxyyline j'ai une j'ai peut-être
reçu une boîte ce matin pour la semaine
on a des pugeries sur des médicaments
antiypertenseurs donc c'est encore plus
aggravé par rapport à l'année dernière
ce qui fait que tous les jours on se bat
avec les médecin pour l'intérêt du
patient pour essayer de trouver une
alternative à des traitements que le
médecin a prescrit parce qu'on les a pas
en stock tout simplement et même si le
mercure devrait remonter dans les
prochains jours santé publique France
voit encore rouge pour la grippe et la
bronchiolite en haut de France pas
question pour le moment de raccrocher
les gros
manteaux inauguré en 1977 le centre pomp
à Paris doit fermer ses portes pour 5 à
7 années de travaux de rénovation le
ministère de la Culture semble empêtré
pourtant dans sa communication avec les
partenaires sociaux les grevistes sont
très remontés et dénoncent une politique
de la sourde d'oreille du côté de la rue
de Valois cette semaine d'ailleurs les
salariés du célèbre musée ont voté la
poursuite de la grève qui dure depuis 13
semaines comme l'a constaté notre
partenaire sur place 20 minutes
TV la situation se durcit au centre
pontpidou après 4 mois de mob isation et
de grève contre la fermeture du musée
qui pourrait durer 7 ans aujourd'hui on
a fait une 1è assemblée général on ne
les compte plus après 13 semaines de
mobilisation depuis le 16 octobre et 2
semaines enfin voilà a énormément de
jours de de de fermeture totale dont les
deux dernières semaines pendant la
période de vacances scolaires ça fait
maintenant des semaines 13 semaines que
les agents du Centre georgees Pompidou
se se mobilisent ils sont inquiets pour
leur à venir et et ça se comprend et il
me paraît important comme parlementaire
parisien de leur apporter de de leur
apporter du soutien on peut pas les
laisser seul face aux questions qui sont
les leurs avec un ministère qui pour
l'instant ne répond pas aux questions
qui lui sont posées il y a une politique
de la sourdeoreill il y a du mépris de
la part du ministère mais il faut bien
voir que la culture elle ne fonctionne
pas sans ses agents on peut peut-être
fonctionner sans ministre mais on peut
pas fonctionner sans agents les
syndicats annoncent d'ors et déjà de
nouvelles actions coup de point dans un
avenir tout proche autre chose dans
l'actualité il y a près de 10 ans les ex
fralibes devenaient scopty après 1336
jours de grève et de lutte contre la
multinationale uni les vers basé à
geménos aux portes de Marseille la
coopérative produit toujours du thé et
des infusions près de 10 ans après la
lutte les collaborateurs de la scopti
ont une autre vision du travail vous
allez le voir Charles Alexandre louas
les a rencontré pour notre partenaire la
Marseillaise sur place bienvenue chez
scopty à gemmenos une entreprise pas
comme les autres depuis 2014 et une
lutte acharnée de 1336 jours contre leur
ancien patron unidever ces salariés se
gèrent euxmême ont tous le même salaire
et prendnent une démarche économique
sociale et
solidaire à l'occasion des 10 ans de
leur émancipation Olivier Leberquier le
directeur anciennement meneur de la
Fronde nous ouvre les portes de son
usine dresse le bilan et les ambitions
pour cette nouvelle alors où est-ce
qu'on est là alors là on est dans
l'atéer de production
et on va aller voir notre ligne sachet
mouseline celle où on conditionne nos
sachet mouselin pour la marque pr 36
comment s déroulé cette année 2023 bah
encore compliqué parce qu'en fait on est
sur trois exercices d'affilé en baisse
de chire d'affaires parce que on a
atteint notre notre meilleur chiffre
d'affaires en 2020 avec le premier
exercice positif mais malheureusement
depuis 2020 bah la crise sanitaire le la
guerre la spéculation autour de la
guerre lesinlation et cetera on fait on
a on est sur trois exercices d'affilé en
recul on terminera donc on avait fait
4002 en 2020 on va faire 33 cette année
2024 on atterrira sûr avec un chiffre
d'affaires autour de 4liion4 45 donc
tout le monde met la main à la Pte la
preuve aujourd'hui voyez sur la ligne
bah c'est notre directeur général qui
fait tourner la la fusion camomie vous
l'aurez compris scopty compte bien se
donner les moyens de péréniser le projet
d'une vie celui qui leur a permis de se
sauver et de leur ouvrir de nouvelles
portes sur
l'avenir quelques 200 40000 fragments de
plastique par litre d'eau c'est
l'inquiétante moyenne décomptée par les
chercheurs américains en analysant l'eau
contenue dans certaines bouteilles en
plastique de consommation courante ces
résultats ont alerté les scientifiques
car cette teneur notamment en
anoplastique est 10 à 100 fois plus
élevé que prévu alors si en métropole
l'eau du robinet est largement
consommable en Martinique en revanche le
recours à l'eau en bouteille est
fréquent et cette étude ne manque pas
d'inquiéter les consommateurs comme ils
l'ont expliqué à Dayana François eudoxy
pour via ATV
Martinique des particules de plastique
100 fois plus importantes qu'estimé dans
les bouteilles d'eau c'est le résultat
d'une étude publiée dans une revue
scientifique américaine dans le rayon de
ce supermarché la nouvelle inquiète
c'est très inquiétant hein parce que ça
ça impacte beaucoup sur la santé très
inquiétant du fait que qu'on consomme on
utilise tous les jours même l'eau du
robinet n'est pas bonne donc on ne sait
plus quoi quoi boire selon l'étude en
buvant 1 lre d'eau de plusieurs marque
populaire c'est en moyenne 240000
fragments de nanoplastique
absorbés essentiellement composé de
pétrrole le plastique est un important
polluant le plastique est polluant et le
plastique libère des particules ces
particules peuvent être libérées quand
on va par exemple brûler le plastique
sous forme donc de fumée et on va
retrouver donc des des produits
extrêmement to
et quand on va ingérer l'eau qui est
présente dans C l'eau de ces bouteilles
bien évidemment il y a il arrive qu'il y
ait aussi des nanoparticules qui peuvent
à long terme et je dis bien sur le très
long terme affecter la santé humaine en
tout cas c'est ce que dit l'OMS des
effets néfastes sur la santé surtout
quand ces bouteilles sont soumises à la
chaleur et les conséquences peuvent être
multiples teles que les cancers he des
cancers multiples des retards en matière
de de développement et parfo fois même
un peu comme le comme le mercure si vous
voulez des des des des problèmes au
niveau à la fois de la fertilité et des
problèmes endocriniens par contre
beaucoup plus graves une nouvelle étude
qui renforce la défiance vis-à-vis de
l'eau en Martinique d'autant que celle
du robinet contiendrait aussi des
fragments de plastique des tests sont
également envisagés pour celle-là voilà
si l'inflation reste une préoccupation
politique majeure pour les Français
comme l'a rappelé le président de la
République lors de sa conférence de
presse à l'Élysée la situation des
étudiants est encore plus problématique
en raison de leur faible niveau de
revenu à Bordeaux le succès des repas à
1 € toujours réservé aux seuls étudiants
boursiers ne se dément pas comme l'a
constaté notre partenaire TV7 la chaîne
du groupe sud-ouest regardez bonjour à
l'heure du déjeuner cet étudiant profite
d'un repas complet à un tarif imbattable
donc ben 1 € s'il vous plaît bonjour
comme lui ils sont aujourd'hui de plus
en plus nombreux à bénéficier d'un repas
à 1 € au lieu de 3,30 € en entrée on va
avoir de du céleri remoulade ensuite on
va avoir des brocolis avec des
butternuts et du riz au curry avec des
petits oignons en dessert on a le choix
généralement un menu entré plat dessert
synonyme de Bouffet d'air frais pour ces
jeunes confronté de plein fouet à la
hausse des prix alors entre MIDH et 2 la
cantine est prise d'assaut là on voit
temp qu'on a pas connu depuis longtemps
qui sont très basses actuellement et
c'est vrai que manger dans un endroit
chaud un repas chaud pour 1 € c'est très
agréable ça facilite vachement dans les
dépenses sachant qu'on n pas énormément
pour pour vivre tout le mois avec avec
les bourses donc ça vient vachement
faciliter ça et c'est vraiment c'est
c'est très très très important je trouve
dans ce restaurant universitaire situé à
proximité du marché des Capucins plus de
la moitié des repass serv sont des repas
à 1 € un dispositif lancé il y a bientôt
3 ans à destination des étudiants
boursiers ou en situation de précarité
devenu indispensable en moyenne depuis
la rentrée depuis le 1er septembre le
midi à 1000 1100 1100 parfois jusqu'à
1200 et le soir entre 150 et 200 2019 on
est à plus de 60 % de fréquentation sur
la même période he 1er septembre 31
décembre au cru de Bordeaux à quiten
plus de 500000 repas à 1 € ont été
servis depuis septembre dernier un
succès fou au point qu'il y ait parfois
de longues files d'attente qu'il faut
prendre en compte durant sa pause
déjeuner le limousie Golden trophée est
un concours de pâtisserie ouvert aux
amateurs limougeot mais organisé par des
professionnels un concours qui prône le
partage des savoir-faire et la
convivialité au point que certaines
créations égalent le travail des
professionnels et ne jouerez pas dans la
vitrine de votre pâtissier préféré pour
cet alimog Alain Druon a eu le le
privilège de goûter ses gâteaux
d'exception et il s'est régalé regardez
merci d'être présent aujourd'hui pour
cette conférence de presse à la mairie
de li c'est le top départ du limouszi
Golden trophé un concours de pâtisserie
ouvert aux amateurs en deux catégories
adolescents et adultes près d'une
centaine de candidats et 22 10 ados et
12 adultes entreront en compétition avec
un niveau très pointu comme l'ont
constaté les membres du jury la
pâtisserie ça se fait quand même avec un
petit peu de rigueur et on peut pas
approcher la pâte ptisserie avec une
certaine légèreté comme on le fait dans
la cuisine 37 gâteaux ont été présentés
au jury si vous voulez goûter vous
pouvez aussi si vous voulez repartir
avec une part vous pouvez également faut
être un petit peu ouais il faut être un
petit peu maniaque pour faire ce métier
mais mais c'est toujours avec
bienveillance je pense qu'il faut le
faire et puis c'est dans un esprit de
partage et pour les membres du jury la
précision compte avant tout l'aspect
esthétique extérieur la découpe si le
gâteau se tient bien et après ben voilà
tout ce que la personne le candidat a a
noté
voir si ça correspond aux
textures puis voilà l'aspect général
c'est propre et puis après on va goûter
ça il y a la créativité parce que il y a
des choses très jolies mais très simples
donc c'est un peu trop facile alors
qu'il y a des gens qui prennent des
risques avec de la créativité donc faut
faire un dosage et puis après on va
goûter alors là ça sera encore une autre
étape il y aura encore deux épreuves
éliminatoires d'ici la finale en public
du 6 avril
prochain depuis 5 ans les frères
millions Rousseau distillateur une cave
atypique à la commune de méoland Revel
dans les Alpes de Haute-Provence et la
partage d'ailleurs avec la coopérative
laitière de la vallée qui fait maturer
ses fromages depuis une vingtaine
d'années dans la vallée de lubaï la
distillerie artisanale la banangeche
fait vieillir le seul et unique whisky
du sud de la France dans un ancien
tunnel ferroviaire c'est un sujet
d'Arthur Soriba pour la Provence à
consommé avec modération ce whisky donc
qui qui a un peu plus de 3 ans de
vieillissement dans la vallée de Luba à
méoland revê depuis 5 ans la distillerie
artisanale la chanangeche fait vieillir
son whisky dans un ancien tunnel
ferroviaire ce nom la ver un peu
atypique du moins sur l'orthographe
c'est un vallon de montagne qui est pas
très loin de la distillerie à quelques
minutes en voiture et le tunnel de
vieillissement dans lequel on opère donc
le vieillissement de ce whisky et au
pied de ce ballon c'est pour relier
toutes les préfectures et
sous-préfectures de France au réseau
ferré national que la percée du tunnel
entre shorg et Barcelonette avait débuté
en
1909 ralenti par la Première Guerre
mondiale les travaux sont définitivement
abandonnés en 1935 et ben il y a de
l'eau la raison avancée le projet du
barrage de serponçon va noyer certains
tronçons nous avons décidé d'investir ce
lieu déjà parce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'espace puisque les bariques doivent
rester 3 ans sur place donc forcément ça
s'accumule et puis c'est une cave très
intéressante de par le taux d'humidité
dans l'air là on est à 90 % d'humidité
dans l'air donc c'est très humide et
puis le peu de variation de température
d'une saison à l'autre et donc ça c'est
très très intéressant pour booster le
vieillissement du whisky et ça apporte
un vieillissement particulier une
signature particulière donc des baries
qui viennent de vin blanc d'appellation
de domaine assez renommé je pense
surtout à mes bariques de Sauterne et
puis plus récemment des bariques de
Nebiolo le Nebiolo c'est un sépage de
vin italien qui est produit dans le
piémon et en
Toscane c'est très très satisfaisant
lancé par leurs parents
994 avec une liqueur de framboise la
distillerie familiale a été reprise en
2019 par François et Gérome qui ont fait
d'elle la première à brasser distyer et
faire vieillir du whisky en région PACA
on a donc développé un pastisce un jean
une liqueur de menthe et puis donc très
plus récemment en tout cas le whisky ça
permet d'aller chercher de nouvelles
pratique de nouvelle manière de
travailler d'essayer de d'innover le
whisky français est en plein boom et on
voulait aussi participer à cette
aventure du whisky français c'est un
sport complet qui permet de pratiquer la
course à pied et le vélo toujours dans
de magnifiques paysage cela a encore été
le cas avec le ride and bike organisé
par le club de triathlon d'ajaacio qui
traversait le domaine viticol de comte
Peraldi Adrien Kouta a d'ailleurs
rencontré les vainqueurs pour télépaiser
sur place regardez une belle course un
beau parcours du soleil une bonne une
bonne ambiance donc un super dimanche
entre copains à se tirer la Bour avec
les autres équipes c'est un parcours que
moi en tant qu'ajaxien de base je
connais bien parce que j'ai beaucoup euh
beaucoup traîné ici beaucoup couru sur
sur les vges de pérag et c'est un
parcours qui est super joueur avec des
des montées des descentes des relances
c'est toujours c'est un effort qui est
très bref très intense sur les hauteurs
du tyot dans les vauges le manteau
neéjeu n'est pas suffisant pour faire
glisser le traîneau d'Antoine gamin
alors ce mûcheur amateur mais passionné
en fourche chaque jour un quad afin de
se préparer à la f Markel slopet course
mythique de chien de traîneau de 600 km
qui aura lieu début mars dans le Grand
Nord norvégien Anaïs Gal et Denis
Lequien l'ont accompagné à
l'entraînement pour vos TV et ça
glisse il s'appell Astrid snow ou indie
pour ne citer queeux et ils ont de
l'énergie à revendre sur les hauteurs du
Tho les 14 chiens de traîneau d'Antoine
gamin s'apprêtent à démarrer leur Séan
quotidienne d'entraînement
l'entraînement il est il est
relativement simple on démarre fin août
début septembre par des petites
distances 6 km et après on augmente au f
à mesure et là en ce moment on est entre
45 et 70 km par 5 fois par semaine des
séances indispensables qui permettront
au chien d'être fin prêts pour les
compétitions qui les attendent en
Norvège d'ici quelques semaines
l'objectif principal c'est de terminer
avec les chiens en forme ça c'est quand
même la chose la plus importante après
il y a quand même la compétition on va
essayer de d'être un petit peu plus
compétitif cette année aussi et puis
après il y a le voyage avec les chiens
c'est carrément quand vous partez sur
600 km c'est c'est une vraie aventure
donc ça c'est vraiment sympa une
expérience hors du temps et riche en
adrénaline que ce mcheur passionné
connaît bien pour y avoir participé à
plusieurs reprises le temps de son
périple il sera accompagné de 8 à 12
chiens les plus performants parmi son
élevage de alaskanovski c'est des chiens
qui courent très longtemps enfin qui
peuvent courir très longtemps et c'est
surtout en fait des chiens qui ont un
très très gros mental donc toujours une
envie de courir en fait donc c'est c'est
vraiment presque ce qui est le plus
important chez le le chien de course et
puisque la neige est encore trop rare
sur les hauteurs vogiennes à défaut de
traînneau la meute tir à un quad mais ce
n'est pas plus mal finalement c'est vrai
que le poids d'un quad est un petit peu
plus lourd on a le moteur quand même
pour les aider à certains endroits mais
c'est vrai qu'après quand on repasse sur
un traîneau qui fait qu'une quinzaine de
kilos pour eux c'est vraiment très
facile de quoi être fin prêt pour
l'échéance qui attend toute l'équipe
d'ici peu une passion dévorante pour la
compétition qui a tout de même un coup
plus de 30000 € par an que le M amateur
finance grâce au sorti baptème qu'il
propose toute l'année dans les vauges en
traîneau ou en carte compé en moyenne 90
€ par adulte pour une session d'
1h30 préserver notre patrimoine coûte
cher après 2 ans de recherche de budget
nécessairire a le Guillaume des travaux
d'ampleur viennent de commencer le
château est en pleine rénovation cet
édifice bâti sur les ruines d'une
forteresse du 11e siècle s'offre une
nouvelle façade vous allez le voir c'est
un château avec une histoire riche et
très variée pour LM TV Sart Colin Ansel
nous raconte cette merveilleuse
histoire il trône majestueux sur les
hauteurs de sel Guillaume successivement
forteresse médiévale préfecture mairie
tribunal prison puis collège après le
don de l'édifice à la commune par
Napoléon du 11e siècle à nos jours le
château a vécu plusieurs vies pendant
ces années de lycéecollège on a ouvert
énormément de portes on a ouvert des
fenêtres et et donc aujourd'hui voilà on
va refermer des fetêtres on va on va
faire un petit un petit changement de la
façade on va vraiment redonner à ce
château une âme de Château j'allais dire
et de le mettre dans son jus du 17e 8
mois de travaux nécessaires pour rénover
le logi est la consécration après 2 ans
de recherche de financement coût du
projet 2250000 € financé à 80 % par les
différentes collectivités après la
façade c'est l'intérieur qui sera
aménagé on compte faire à l'intérieur
des espac muséographiqu ou des espaces
sur l'histoire du château on a aussi une
belle collection d'arsenne Marie
Lefeuvre qui est un artiste silléen qui
a dessiné bébé cadom pour la marque
valoriser le territoire valoriser un
patrimoine immatériel aussi voilà qui
fait aussi l'importance de ser dans
l'histoire beaucoup d'autres projets
sont déjà à l'étude pour valoriser cet
édifice et l'ouvrir à tous c'est pas
uniquement le château de la ville de sil
Guillaume c'est le château de tous les
habitants c'est le château de d'un
territoire on a déjà un abondement de la
Fondation du Patrimoine on sait qu'on a
un dossier qui est parti à la Fondation
Berne tout ça ça déclenche de d'autres
aides qui seront importantes pour
l'avenir de la restauration de ce
château et c'est un plaisir de
travailler sur des sur des projets comme
ça mais le ner de la guerre c'est
l'argent donc il n faut de l'argent pour
cela il est possible de soutenir la
réflexion du château en allant sur le
site de la Fondation du Patrimoine
malgré les travaux l'édifice sera ouvert
aux visites cet
été voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
édition du Grand JIT des territoires au
revoir à
[Musique]
tous